>> Let's be clear, drinking milk is a really
important trait. In fact, it defines an entire group
in the animal kingdom called mammals, which we are.
Mammals are defined as a group of animals that
can breast feed their young with breast milk. And
this is possible because we have a lactase gene
that's transcribed and translated into the lactase protein, which
is able to metabolize lactose found in breast milk.
>> And breast milk is one of the best sources of nutrients
for newborn babies. But eventually we grow up and we
grow out of drinking breast milk and on to solid foods.
>> This process, this transition from going from breast milk to solid food is
something we call weaning. And there are lots of changes that happen when an
animal actually is weaned off of breast milk. And one of the most important
changes relevant to what we're talking about
is that, that lactase gene turns off.
>> However, a recent mutation at least in
an evolutionary sense, allows the lactase gene to stay turned on, which
allows us to drink lactose products throughout our life. For example, milk.
>> This mutation or change in the DNA sequence.
I want you to tell me if you think it
actually occurs in the coding region of the lactase
gene or the non-coding regions of the lactase gene. Go
ahead and pick which answer you think is the
best, and put in your best reason in the text
box here. Don't worry about getting the text box
answer right or wrong, just give it your best shot.